uh so we're Team 25 um I'm Aditya you're
um I'm Denise Mara
and by the time I'm finished saying the
sentence the students already dropped
out of school that's just
wrong um just let's face face it
students like me today AR engaged with
what schools have to offer for kids
they're as Matthew Malone said yesterday
they're teaching the same thing they did
quite a few years ago so we wanted to um
Inspire students um creative instincts
their um intrinsic motivic motiv
motivation to learn yeah so our solution
is a cross-disciplinary course prompted
by students Ben loves soccer and
chemistry and he's curious to explore
both subjects but he doesn't know how
they are actually compatible so today in
class he receives this form where he's
asked what his two main interest St so
he answers and um get Ben gets spared
with two teachers who get him will guide
him through the UN known Journey um
he'll be also organized into groups of
students with similar interests so sorry
next Friday uh Ben will be part of mix
it up Ben and his classmates that uh are
around him with similar interests will
come together and start working on an
independent and integrative project um
this way uh throughout the semester
students will come up with their own
content and manage their own projects uh
with Ben with the help of his teachers
will not only fulfill existing class
competencies but um also get to uh get
to explore his Natural Curiosity and
intrinsic
motivation so basically what we want to
do is we want to develop the survey
that's going to ask students what
they're interested in what they want to
learn about um and then we're going to
create a manual for a collabor ation
between the students and the teachers
that they're going to be working with to
develop their own curriculum I'm going
kind of change the teacher student
relationships that's in traditional
schools and then we're going to do this
stuff is this uh PD is this the core of
it you got to get teachers trained to
implement basically it's a Grassroots
model um and so we want to have like
mixed up champions in every school um
that teach their other professionals and
teachers in their school how to how to
collaborate with students and and figure
out what their interest in learning um
so increasing their professional
development but also making it
autonomous within the school
itself uh no I don't know the name the
it'll be part of a way of schools to be
like the rise the race to the top race
to the top sorry the race to the top
structure so they will be encouraged to
uh implement this project this system so
that they can raise the top and get more
funding ranking
based so it's it's it's in integrated
with the same course competencies that's
already in the system so even though
it's a new course it's still fulfilling
a lot of the systemic stuff that we
already have to deal with yeah while
giving students autonomy and helping
teachers and students be engaged
together and with u a different
perspective you know yes mixing two
courses that would usually not be put
together and um Crea students are
interested in yeah so any other
questions what happens when the uh the
two interests fall out of a perview of a
school or the right so there's there's
another stakeholder that's definitely
the professionals and so when they're
creating this uh this class it's going
to be like before the semester that
they're going to take it in so it's like
what people do we need to contact that
we don't have the resources for and how
do we contact them and who's who's most
appropriate um and and it changes that's
why we survey students every year
because we want to be able to Sol the
trends and have real time learning so it
becomes a sustainable and always growing
um
mechanism thank you everyone
for